you  man you guys common up fanboys bro did  he just did he just say call me na think  we just did I think it's I think it's  coming up buddy what do you watch dogs  or something sometimes yeah man  sometimes I don't want to read you got a  problem with I got a problem with a bro  I got my god yo what ya right now at the  park right now at the Florida see that's  the part 10 minutes man you're on going  around all are going on like Donkey Kong  it's on like mario party for ya see you  at the park [ __ ] yeah yeah  now we're going to mess them up man  wanna [ __ ] him up real good fishing pole  even to you that believes in me  believe me  you  hard two cards [ __ ] you change of heart  cyber dragon [ __ ] oh ha we win brah  yeah round two [ __ ] oh my boys ready  yes why can you throw me all right round  three fight to the death  hahaha prepare to die oh [ __ ] well you  guys like enemy may I loved avatar like  making a Korra